Election Day in the United States is
Tuesday November 6th Tuesday November 6
which is just around the corner 435
seats in the House of Representatives
will be contested 39 governorships
and so much more this is your chance you
can make a difference you can make a
difference just keep two things in mind
first you need to be an American citizen
over the age of 18 and second second
you need to be registered registered
registered register registered 20 I'm
not I'm not I'm not registered
so yeah I'm not registered to vote and
if I want a boat I have to register
pretty much now and since I'm from
Philadelphia I one register in
Pennsylvania so I've been doing some
research and I can go to City Hall to
register in Philadelphia so what I need
to do is go to Penn Station get on the
train get the Trent and then take it
over to my parents's house change get to
the city of Philadelphia register to
vote let's do it all right so I'm
heading over to Penn Station right now
there's a bunch of American flags so I'm
just gonna follow the American flags I'm
sure they'll lead me to wherever you
have to register hopefully that's right
[Music]
[Music]
two-hour train ride let's go get
registered all right so I just got to my
parents house I'm gonna change real
quick because I'm going to City Hall I
need to look presentable so my parents
left to work so I have no car to get to
the train station to get to the city to
get to City Hall so I'm just gonna walk
there and when I forgot to lock the door
it's raining are you kidding me oh my
gosh this is terrible
[Music]
okay I'm in a huge station I've made it
into the city now I need to find City
Hall I think it's like a five minute
walk from here all right we made it how
do you enter this place where where am i
walking
am i right now
okay I think I walked the wrong way do
you know where I go if I'm trying to
register to vote 140 on the other side
do you know where the voter registration
is that way think about this place just
keeps going on where am I
I clean through here
I'm walking here there it is
so I couldn't register a boat because I
live in New York so I can't register in
PA and I have to go back to New York I'm
at the building I'm gonna go and
register please work hopefully this
works let's go
I did it was so much work that was so
much that was way too complicated you
need to be registered registered
registered registered and registering is
easy this year BuzzFeed is partnering
with turbo vote so you can register
online today what you're serious
I could have done this online this is
this is it's distancing I went all the
way to another state to register when
everybody knew Krish I want to get
reimbursed for my train tickets and my
[Music]